la pandemia durará un año más de lo
necesario por la desigualdad de las
vacunas la razón los países más pobres
no están recibiendo suficientes dosis
según el organismo mundial de la salud
esto significa que la pandemia podría
prolongarse fácilmente hasta el 2022
según los datos proyectados en la web
our world in that a poco menos del 8% de
la población de áfrica ha recibido una
dosis de la vacuna esto contrasta con
otras regiones del mundo en eeuu y
canadá el 67 por ciento de la población
cuenta con al menos una dosis en américa
latina' el 61 por ciento mientras que en
europa llega al 58 por ciento y en asia
al 57 para abordar el problema el año
pasado se estableció un programa de
distribución de vacunas a nivel mundial
en el que los países más ricos se
comprometieron a donar dosis y a
subsidiar los costos para las naciones
más pobres conocido como kóvacs su
objetivo inicial era proporcionar 2 mil
millones de vacunas en todo el mundo
este año una meta que no se cumplirá
ahora se espera que el programa cuente
con un total de 1.400 millones de dosis
para finales de 2021 el lunes la unión
europea aseguró que planea aumentar las
donaciones de vacunas los países más
vulnerables kim hyunjoon la unión
europea ha exportado más de mil millones
de vacunas contra el coi 19 al resto del
mundo rest of words with entregamos
alrededor de 87 millones de dosis a los
países de ingresos bajos y medianos a
través de kóvacs así que cumplimos
nuestra promesa oms sin embargo un
análisis de people's boxing una alianza
de organizaciones benéficas muestra que
sólo una de cada siete de las dosis
prometidas por las naciones más ricas y
las compañías farmacéuticas está
llegando a su destino en los países más
pobres